los tipos socks andrei duda da positivo
por kobe 19 el presidente polaco es uno
de los pocos líderes mundiales
confirmados con el virus
polonia es uno de los países menos
golpeados en europa pero este viernes
registró un nuevo récord de contagios al
igual que varios de sus vecinos europeos
la segunda ola del brote se recrudece en
el continente con un récord de 42 mil
nuevos casos en 24 horas francia alcanzó
el millón de contagios después de españa
este fin de semana el parlamento
debatirá un proyecto de ley para
prorrogar el estado de urgencia
sanitaria que le permitiría al gobierno
de endurecer su dispositivo anti kobe
alemania por su parte llegó a los 10.000
fallecidos la organización mundial de la
salud instó a los líderes a tomar
medidas inmediatas para evitar más
muertes y colapsos en el sistema de
salud we are the critical yankee estamos
en una coyuntura crítica de esta
pandemia particularmente en el
hemisferio norte los próximos meses van
a ser muy duros y algunos países están
en un camino peligroso sham countries
aaron a danger strike
en italia los casos se han multiplicado
por siete desde principios de este mes
roma- entró este viernes en un toque de
queda nocturno al igual que nápoles pero
allí sus residentes salieron a las
calles para rechazar el confinamiento
los toques de queda se han convertido en
una opción para los países europeos con
el fin de frenar la propagación del
virus
todos han recurrido a medidas variadas
para evitar un cierre general que pueda
volver a golpear duramente la economía